Bashar al-assad is a pretty famous face
around the world and one that people are
pretty familiar with most people know
that he is the current president of
Syria and has been so for the last 20
years our people don't know not a lot of
people at least is that he and a large
portion of the government in Syria
belonged to a secretive religious
minority who are known as the Allah
weeds the Allah weeds are a religious
minority that is situated primarily in
Syria along the Mediterranean coast and
on the inaccessible mountain Jebel Ali
Wayne or double no Syria there are
sometimes also known as Messiah T's but
both of these names can be derogatory
and have political undertones so beware
of that during this video I will be
using them both but with these sort of
background knowledge of their very
complex history it appears that the
nameless sadie's was the most common or
universal name for this group prior to
the 1920s after which the name al awaits
was will start to be used but we'll
return to this soon it's also important
to remember that the AL awaits are not
the same as the olive ease in Turkey
even if the names are very similar and
they also share share certain aspects
that are similar but aside from this
these are two very different distinct
groups they are a very secretive and
esoteric group which means that we know
very little about their history or their
teachings even less so than a lot of the
other religious groups that have
discussed in previous videos there is
also an ongoing debate as to brother the
other weights are a unique religion of
their own or if they belong to Shia
Islam and there are different branches
and schools within the Alawite religion
which makes this question a lot more
complex and complicated as well despite
this serious lack of information there
is some general information that recurs
in descriptions of this community some
state that it originated with the figure
Muhammad upon the Sayre an ahmadi who
lived in the ninth century in iraq and
from which the name nurseries derive he
said to have been a
students of the 10th and 11th Shia Imams
of the Twelver Shia branch Ali al-hadi
and Hasan Askari where things become
especially interesting is that even the
say it began to view himself as they
kind of prophets according to certain
sources and the two Imams as being
divine he was given a revelation of
sorts through al-askari which from the
basis of his new religion one that
distanced itself from Islamic law and
practice the movement was further
established in Syria by abdullah al
Husseini ben Hamdan al-hasa be and
especially in the early 11th century by
Sir Reuben Kasim al tabarani the latter
Alta Bharani is often considered the
founder of the religion in Syria as he
was able to convert a significant amount
of people in the mountain area along the
coast which has since been the center
for the Alawite religion the beliefs and
practices of the Alouettes are very
fascinating and unique remember we know
very little about their religion due to
their very secretive nature they have
very rarely disclosed their teachings to
outsiders or even to people within the
faith itself so we know very little but
from what we do know about their faith
and their practices it seems that this
religion or this branch of Islam however
you choose to look at it is one that is
very syncretic so it contains elements
from Islam and from Greek traditions
like neoplatonism and Gnosticism as well
as Christianity and a certain local
Syrian pre-islamic traditions as well
the most important book or scripture for
Alouettes is known as kitab al mismo the
book of the collection which may have
been authored by Alta Bharani whom I
mentioned but some other way it's also
claimed that this book is a forgery so
we're not exactly sure and those who
emphasize their being part of Islam also
point to the Quran as a very important
Scripture a book for the other weights
in any case a very common narrative
regarding how that with belief is that
at the beginning of creation the other
weights were lights that surrounded God
and praised him
but after a revolt they were punished by
being sent down to earth in earlene in
physical bodies and to undergo the
process of rebirth
so here already is a very unique aspect
of this faith is that they believe in
the transmigration of the soul or in
other words reincarnation so according
to this teaching earthly life is seen in
a very negative light almost like a kind
of punishment and similar to religions
like Hinduism the goal of life then is
to escape or be freed from this cycle of
rebirths
and re-enter heaven as stars of light
perhaps the most central aspect of their
religious beliefs and the one that has
been probably the most controversial to
muslims is their very unique
relationship to a little benefit Aled
the cousin and son-in-law of the Prophet
Muhammad as well as the 4th caliph and
first Imam of the Shia Muslims what is
universally accepted is that they very
much revere and hold Ali in a very
higher regard but according to many
sources the relationship goes even
further than that it is claimed that a
proclamation of faith of the Alouettes
is that I profess that there is no god
but Adi indeed it seems according to
scripture and the information that we
have that Ali is seen as God or an
incarnation or manifestation of God
according to at least many Allah weights
historically although those Alouettes
today that want to emphasize that they
are part of Islam tend to reject this
idea in any case it seems that Alouettes
believed that God has been incarnated or
manifested seven times in history but
that no one really got the message until
the last time these incarnations are
called manna and when we look at who
they are the answer is pretty surprising
they are able Seth Joseph Joshua Asif
Peter
and lastly Ali these all seem to be
relatively secondary figures in the
biblical and Quranic narratives they are
often associates of great prophets but
who were never great prophets themselves
and this very interestingly is because
according to Allah with belief every
time God is in kearney
human being he also sends certain lower
associates called an ism the name or
al-hajj of the veil and Al Bob which
means the gate as we have guessed at
this point al is Marta job or usually
those who are considered great prophets
and thus include Adam Noah Jacob Moses
Solomon Jesus and Mohammed these
prophets are thus only foreshadowings
who also veil and hide the true identity
of God in his real manifestation no
wonder people never got the message
each mana and ism or hijab is also
accompanied by a gate and Bob not all of
which are known but so to take an
example in the last manifestation of God
in Ali Ali then is mana God's
manifestation Muhammad is the veil or
name which conceals Ali's true identity
as God and the gate while bob is salman
al-farsi
it was thought to be the first persian
convert to islam so every time God has
manifested himself he does so through
this kind of triad the last and final of
which was that of Ali there are certain
holidays and religious festivals or
celebrations which we know of which
again showcases the other weights very
syncretic nature of this religion one of
these is known as could this in which
bread and wine is consumed and it is
thought that Ali is incarnated in the
wine which draws clear parallels to
Christianity obviously Allah waits can
also celebrate Christmas no rules or
Persian New Year a they'll fit and it'll
add her as well as Ashura but these
holidays have often been emptied of
their existing contents and
reinterpreted through Allah with belief
Allah waits don't fast during Ramadan
for example even if they do celebrate a
festival called even fitted also a Shura
which is a Shiite day of crimson of the
death and martyrdom of Imam Hussein is
given a different flavor by Allah
weights as they don't actually believe
that her say never died on the
battlefield but that he went into
spiritual occultation or
Alouettes don't seem to have a mosque or
any specific place of worship but
instead tend to perform prayers at home
and it is said that these prayers are to
be done five times a day but this
apparently isn't that strictly observed
today
[Music]
the Alouettes have since the Middle Ages
been very much contained or centralized
to the coastal regions in Syria along
the Mediterranean coast they have been a
rather controversial group as many
Muslim scholars and jurists have
considered them heretics or non-muslims
for example during mom look times there
appears to have been campaigns or
efforts to convert the Alouettes who
were then known as nurseries to Islam by
building mosques in the other way
villages on this topic the very famous
Muslim traveler and writer eben Battuta
really very interesting section about
the group quote most who live in this
coastal region belonged to the no
society sect it is they who believe that
Ali is a God they don't pray and they
don't do the ritual ablutions they don't
even celebrate the month of fasting al
Malik Azha had forced them to build
mosques in the villages and they did
build a mosque in every village but far
from their homes and they neither use
nor maintain them they even keep their
sheep and donkeys there sometimes
strangers come to their land and stop by
a mosque and call to prayer then they
may call to him and say stop crying you
shall soon have your father this sect is
large in numbers there appears to have
been periods of great oppression men
during Ottoman times many many of the
lo8 lands were confiscated and the
Alouettes were forced to work as poor
farmers after the rule of the ottomans
and under the rule of the french the
nefarious rolla weights were given
autonomy and was supported by the
colonial masters as is often the case
the colonial powers often supported
minority groups in their bid to
destabilize the region and create
opposition to these Sunni majority it is
here in the 20th century that some of
the most significant developments take
place within this religious group many
new societies were so poor that they
were forced to enlist in the military or
work for the state in Syria which begins
their strong relationship with the
government at the same time in the 1920s
the name Allah weights was applied for
the first time whereas no series had
been the common term prior to this
the name Allawi comes from the name of
ali and the change can be said to be a
way to convey their closeness to Shia
Islam partly to gain greater acceptance
by other Muslims in the region but also
to stand in opposition to the Sunnis
which of course gladden the French and
British powers a lot in fact the
question of their relationship or their
status as Muslims or non-muslims is a
very contested issue and debate there
appears to have been in the 20th century
a conscious efforts on part of the other
weights themselves to move closer to
Islam and twelve-hour if naxi shiism in
particular with the coup that resulted
in half is al-assad becoming president
of syria in 1971 and as the constitution
requires that the president be muslim
there has been a campaign to prove that
the ala weights are simply a branch of
Twelver she ISM something that many Shia
and Sunni Muslim scholars have a firm
that's true but many also see this
Islamization simply as a political
strategy or a tool after the death of
Hafez al-assad in 2000 his son Bashar
al-assad took over and is still the
sitting president the Alouettes have a
very strong presence in the politics of
Syria today with some estimates showing
that maybe 80% of the Alawis population
work in the government in some fashion
the question of their identity is one
that is continuously debated many argue
that the Alouettes today can be divided
into two branches one that is called the
new societies and one that's called the
Alouettes the Alouettes being those who
want to emphasize their closeness to
Shia Islam while the Society's being
those who retain or preserves some of
the more unique aspects historically of
this religious group one also sometimes
divided the other weights into three
other branches the camera more CD and
Shanxi branches for the Sham sees the
Prophet Muhammad has an equal if not
superior role to ally the motions on the
other hand are based on a movement
started by Suleiman Al Murshid who in
the 1920s claimed to be a prophet and
raised an army to revolt against the
Syrian state
the Mercedes seemed to view Salomon
emotion as being divine somehow and
lastly are the Camrys who are in a
majority and these are the Alouettes who
seem to believe that Ali is God clearly
according to these divisions and this
internal diversity much of what I've
said in this video is open for debate
and there appears to be differing
viewpoints within the faith itself so
this is very important to remember the
other weights are thus a diverse
fascinating and very secretive religious
minority group that we know very little
about
they hold significant political power in
Syria through the Assad family and they
have a long and complex history in this
region the question whether or not they
are Muslims is not up to me to decide or
answer but as we've seen from this video
there are many complexities and nuances
to this debate that make it very
complicated I would love to hear your
opinions and to keep this discussion
going in the comments as always and if
you want to support the channel you can
like the video and subscribe I'll see
you next time
[Music]